das klingt echt wie eine
nachrichtenmeldung aus fantasien jedes
auto kann von heute auf morgen zu einem
elektroauto werden ohne irgendeinen
umbau einfach so ja das ist tatsächlich
möglich ist heißt die lösung also
elektro kraftstoffe wie bitte die
auflösung jetzt bei pixum science
fiction herzlich willkommen das ist
wirklich verrückt jedes auto könnte von
heute auf morgen mit strom angetrieben
werden und dabei müsste das fahrzeug
überhaupt nicht verändert werden kein
umbau keine kosten einfach so die lösung
strom wird verwendet um den treibstoff
herzustellen und das erfolgt dann
vollkommen klimaneutral wenn die energie
mit der regenerativen energiequellen
erzeugt wird also wasser sonne wind und
das wäre dann auch eine lösung um die
stromspitzen zb bei der windkraft
abzufangen und den strom zu speichern
die lösung heißt ich will hier wird
zunächst per elektrolyse wasser in
wasserstoff und sauerstoff aufgeteilt
das ist super simpel einfach ein plus
und minuspol ins wasser halten strom
drauf und am minuspol an der kathode
wird reiner wasserstoff erzeugt und an
der anode dem pluspol reiner sauerstoff
schon die beiden sind ein absolut
explosives gemisch und reagieren extrem
schnell und exklusiven miteinander
eigentlich ideal als treibstoff in
wasserstoff autos wird wasserstoff ja
auch verwandt allerdings geht das nicht
mit herkömmlichen verbrennungsmotoren
dafür muss der wasserstoff mit co2
zusammen gebunden werden und schon haben
wir kohlenwasserstoff und damit je nach
methode benzin kerosin gas und so weiter
und so fort und co2 ja das haben wir ja
mehr als genug es kann aus der luft
zurück gewonnen werden aus biogasanlagen
gewonnen werden oder mit anderen
technologien erzeugt werden entscheidend
mitentwickelt hat dieses verfahren
michael sterner er ist professor für
energiespeicher und energiesysteme an
der technischen hochschule regensburg
und wurde für diese power to liquid und
power to gas technik mehrfach
ausgezeichnet und es könnte wirklich die
zwischenlösung sein bis die reichweite
von elektrofahrzeugen mindestens auf
eine tagesreise
auch auf autobahnen gestiegen ist und
sie in wenigen minuten geladen werden
können zwischenlösungen weil diese
technik nicht besonders effizient ist
der wirkungsgrad liegt bei rund 2
20 bis 30 und noch ist der kraftstoff
ziemlich teuer letzteres würde sich aber
nach der markteinführung schnell ändern
und man müsste die mehrkosten verrechnen
die im moment entstehen weil
kohlekraftwerke die netze belegen und
windkraftanlagen deswegen abgeschaltet
werden müssen dann wird dieser
treibstoff plötzlich sogar richtig
preiswert weil ausschließlich über
kapazitäten für die produktion von e
views genutzt werden würden bei
elektrofahrzeugen liegt übrigens der
wirkungsgrad bei 70 prozent und strom
sogar billiger als fossile brennstoffe
und das auch langfristig allerdings
steht die politik mal wieder auf der
bremse bremse laut stern will man hier
erst das netz ausbauen bevor energie
gespeichert wird das wird ungefähr noch
zwölf jahre dauern dann sind dann mal
eben 40 milliarden euro verpulvert
worden
da könnte ich ja mal wieder dampf
ablassen oh man also wenn ihr kein video
zum thema elektroautos das ist ja eines
meiner lieblingsthemen und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesslich den genau auf die glocke nur
dann werde sie auch über neue videos
informiert hier geht es weiter und dafür
unbedingt draufklicken bald nur noch
elektroautos technik vor
technologiesprung ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran